Since Donald Trump's election, white,
Evangelical Christians have been a
critical part of his base. Evangelical
leaders are among the first to defend
him from criticism and forgive his
ethical lapses, but young, white,
Evangelicals expressed far less
enthusiasm for Trump and his politics.
There's a 30-point gap between younger
and older white evangelicals and views
of Trump, and here's why: first, for many
young, white, Evangelicals, the
immigration issue is complicated. Most say
immigrants contribute positively to
America's economy and culture. The
shifting cultural landscape, increasing
secularization, and a growing nonwhite
population, simply don't register among
young Evangelicals as a problem. In this
way their lives are dramatically
different from their parents. Numerically,
they are already in the minority, and
young adults today are more likely to
know an atheist than an Evangelical Christian.
Despite this, Trump is still
poised to make off with the lion's share
of votes among young, white, Evangelical
Christians, but he is likely redefining
the relationship they have with the GOP.
The implications that could have for our
politics, and Evangelical Christianity,
could be profound.
How important do you think young, white, Evangelicals will be in the 2020 election? Let us know in our
poll. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
Seconds, and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.